- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is believe.
Over to you, Tech Nine.
(air whooshing)
(basketball dribbling)
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- You have to push for
it, if it's in your heart.
Because I'm from Kansas City, Missouri,
who would have ever thought
that you can build an empire,
but if you put your mind to it,
and push for it, and push for it.
No matter if your family
tell you it's a hobby,
you need to do something else to get money
or whatever, man, it's
like if you believe in it,
you got to follow that
dream in your heart, man.
Because if I didn't there wouldn't be
any strange music to
come do any interview in.
Because I followed my dream,
after everybody knocked me down.
You have to push for it,
if you believe in it,
you will achieve in it.
Just got to keep pushing,
that's what I have to say.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going